Big news in maths! There's a new tile in town;
so we've come to the town of
Newtyle to see what it's all about.
So you know your regular floor tiles? How
they you know they go over and over, they
cover the entire plane with a pattern? This
new tile goes infinitely but with no repeats.
Happy new tile! Okay, so an aperiodic monotile
- what's this all about? We need to break that word
down. First of all we need to understand what
tiling is or tessellation; so let's look at- I
mean probably the most simple shape that tiles,
triangle. When we tessellate triangles it tends
to be a kind of one up, one down, tooth situation
going on. And every single triangle tessellates.
even the scalene ones. And what that means is that
they fit together beautifully like you would see
on a pavement or a wall - no gaps and no overlaps. So
those are the the two main rules: they fit together,
no gaps, no overlaps. So every single triangle
tessellates, every single quadrilateral tessellates;
so if we were to find a kind of new tiling
that had a new property where it wasn't periodic
it would have to at least be five sides. So-
- (Brady: Hang on, periodic?)
- Yes, okay, periodic - the second part of this.
If you can tessellate in such a way that there is
translational symmetry, so the same section repeats
over and over again - ooh second colour. This section here,
I can pick that up and move it over and it looks
exactly the same as this section down here. Okay.
So this is periodic because it has translational
symmetry, it's got a regular repeating pattern
over and over again; you can see how you would
take even just a section of two of them, section
of three of them, any arbitrary amount and you can
find another patch that looks exactly the same and
you can pick the entire tessellation up - so this is
what we mean by global. The entire tessellation
up, move it all over, and maybe up 1, up 2, and
it will look exactly the same, fit in exactly whereit was before.
- (For different shapes presumably that)
(repeatable bit can be more and more complicatedI imagine?)
- Yeah it can. So I think that's called
a primitive unit? If you have an interesting
combination that you can move around - hexagons
looks quite cool, but you could do it with one
hexagon as well. Animation guy: have fun with that.
Mathematicians have discovered a brand new kindof tile.
(This is periodic?)
- Yes, this is periodic and it's a tiling.
What we are aiming for is an aperiodic tiling and
we have tons of them actually; they've existed
for a long time. I guess the most famous one-
(You've got the Penrose tiling?)
- Yeah I really
didn't think this would go out of date.
(But it did.)
- I- I am shocked by the news but surprised and
you know I've got more space. The Penrose tiling
is - was - the the lowest amount of tiles that we
could have which made this aperiodicity happen.
It forced aperiodicity to happen. So the Penrose
tiling is either made of kites and darts or a kind
of wide rhombus and a thinner rhombus. On their
own they definitely tile periodically; but with
the Penrose tiling it's a set of the two of
them, so you need two tiles to make it happen,
and there's these- they're called matching rules.
So sometimes you can do it with little notches
and it forces you to tile them in such a way that
there will never be a translational symmetry. So
you pick the whole thing up, you move it around, it
never looks the same. You might notice that there
are some bits which look like they repeat. I do
love that his name is Penrose; it's got this kind
of pentagonal rose motif that comes up. How come if
you can see repeats we're saying it's non-repeating?
It's okay to have local repeats, those little bits
that look the same, but if you were to pick up the
whole tessellation - move it around and try and find
somewhere else it fits - you're not gonna find it. So
Penrose needed to - and this was an open problem
for a long time - could it even be done? Absolute
mystery. Mathematicians didn't know if there could
be an aperiodic tiling. Then when they found them
they needed much much much more than 2. I think
the first set was over 20,000 tiles. And then it
was a kind of one upping between mathematicians;
you know, who can get it down to 11? Who can get
it down to 6? And so you've got all of these
different Berger tiles, Wang tiles, then Penrose
got it down to 2. Which he said, I believe in
the podcast, that he was surprised how easy it was.
To which I say, how come it took so long to
find just the 1? The mono tile then?
- (So after)
(the Penrose tiling was there like a big race for
a mono tile? Was this- was this the thing people)
(were looking for? Or had people sort of left this
area of research and thought 2 was as good asit gets?)
I think people wanted to find it but the
faith wasn't there. I certainly did not believe
that it was possible. You know I'm a little bit
younger, so I was not around in the the 60s and
the 70s when there was this big tiling boom. And I
convinced myself that if I had been around in the
70s all of this amazing tiling mathematical fame
was ripe for the picking and I absolutely would
have staked my claim and found a cool tile. And now
I know for a certain that's not true because here
I am in the year 2023, this incredibly simple
shape was just waiting to be found and I did
not find it. I'm a mathematician and there's just
been a new tile discovered. Mathematicians have
been looking for it for about 60 years. So it's
called The Hat.
- (Do you think it looks like a hat?)
I can see it as a hat. I I did actually- I asked
Craig Kaplan who was part of the team, because
clearly it looks like a t-shirt, an untucked
t-shirt. So I asked him why hat instead of
t-shirt and it was just a case of ergonomics; um
it's much easier to write the word hat over and
over again and if you squint it does look like
a hat. I don't think he he even saw that it was
clearly t-shirt shaped beforehand, but there's
plenty of artworks of it looking like a t-shirt.
So this is the solution, this is what we've
posed as the solution to the Einstein problem
um which is a pun yep - um meaning one stone. We
can now tile the entire plane, the infinite plane,
without any translational symmetry and only this
one stone. You won't be able to find another place
that's exactly the same. And it's a result so
nicely proved it twice.
- (Is it one stone?)
- I mean...I
just want to say that I love it, I think it's the
best. I believe that this counts as one stone.
When you look at the tiling - so here's
a little bit of a tiling I made earlier-
the purple ones you might notice they are flipped
over. So I mean I could take this this purple one
out here and if I try and put them directly on
top they don't entirely line up because they are
in fact mirror images. Some of them are flipped
over; the tiling wouldn't work if there weren't
some flipped over. I still think it's a mono
tile, I believe that we've titled the entire
plane with one shape. Uh there are there are some
camps where people don't want the the flipped
over tile. The ratio between the flipped over
tiles to the the regular forward-the-way tiles
- you're not ready for this - it's the
golden ratio to the power of 4 to 1.
(There's obviously a good reason for that hidden
in the maths)
- It's to do with eigenvectors yeah.
So for every 1 flipped over tile you need
roughly 6 forward tiles; but that roughly 6
is actually the golden ratio to the power of 4.
It would have to be irrational for an aperiodic.
Hello! Future Ayliean here but only one week in the
future. So just after we finished filming this
video, the same team discovered this: the ultimate
monotile. It tiles aperiodically but with no
cheeky reflections, it's a twist on the original.
And future-future Ayliean will tell you about it as
soon as I can but right now I'm gonna hand back to
past Ayliean to tell you about the old new monotile.
(You said something about they proved it twice?
Because this does seem like it'll be something)
(that would be hard to prove)
- Umm yeah and I feel
like hard to prove but almost one of them is
inevitable. So there's the standard proof which a
lot of other aperiodic titles use, which involves
super tiles and meta tiles. So it's not the first
tile which is- is a singular tile which can do
aperiodic tiling.
- (What?!)
- To be very precise, thereare just maybe infinitely - definitely infinitely-
many other tiles that have this property.
Let's look at one of them at least. Here's
a puzzle from this very old book: a farmer had
a square field but had to sell a quarter of it.
This quarter is gone. When he died his four sons
split up the remainder in four equal portions
and each piece had exactly the same shape. How did
they do it? Do you want to have a go?
- (I'm wondering)
(if it's going to involve triangles?)
- A lot ofpeople go for that first of all.
- Yeah? But no?
So if you do the triangles you can split
it into four triangles which are all 1, 1,
root two right angle triangles but two of them are
bigger and we want to make sure that everyone gets
the the same share here. It's worth having a
few seconds to think about this, it's a nice puzzle.
Looks like a fairly old set of tiles in
Newtyle. We'll update it? Okay.
(You found a four leaf clover?)
- Oh course I found a four leaf clover
- (You just saw it?)
Yeah it'sright there, you see?
- (How did you just see that?)
I'm gonna leave this right here.
The way that we're
gonna do this, not immediately obvious, but we're
going to take this shape that was left over, it's
called the L-shaped triominal, and we're going to
make a smaller version of it. So I've split it up,
there's a smaller version there, and then I'm gonna
split it like this. And now we've got four of the
same shape so all of the sons are happy, they've
all got the same size, the same shape piece. You
might notice, because they're all the same shape as
the larger shape we can do that again but smaller.
I could take this one here and I could split that
up, put another L shape on there. And I could keep
that going for as long as I like. Oh do you know
what these are called? Because they're a tile that
replicates themselves they're called a rep-tile
Okay so this has the the property that we're
looking for; this creates an aperiodic tiling.
(That feels like it's repeat-y but it's not)
- Yeah, well you- it's got the same thing where you know
you pick it up, you move it around, you can't
um you can't translate it - no translational
symmetry. A lot of them have this kind of locally
repeating motifs; it feels repeat-y. You know, when
you think about an aperiodic tiling you might
think oh this is gonna go into absolute chaos;
there's a surprising amount of structure involved
in aperiodicity because- I mean aperiodicity is
almost like a border case. You've got things
which don't tile at all, they leave gaps, they
leave overlaps; things which periodically tile,
you know they've got a good strong tiling - squares,
rectangles, I mean any quadrilateral - and then right
on the line between tiling periodically and not
tiling at all you have aperiodic tiles. So so it's
it's a very difficult boundary edge case to find
and so there is a lot of structure involved in
making this happen.
- (Why has this thing here even)
(made news? What's so special about these Einstein
tile things?)
- Okay so this shape here, yes it can
aperiodically tile as can many other shapes. I
really hope that your animation person puts
a pinwheel tailing in? They're very nice. And
that's just a triangle and we've spoken about
those. So these can tile periodically. I could
if I want take some L shapes and I could take
another L shape and kind of fit them together
like this and I could keep that going, and this
would make a periodic tile. So what's the new
thing is that this can't. You can try as hard as
you want but you will never be able to get this to
periodically tile - and that's how it was discovered.
So David Smith who is a geometry hobbyist, he
was playing around with these different shapes,
kind of came across what what this is called the
polykite and tried to tile it in a periodic way
and couldn't. And he thought okay this must
be some sort of issue, maybe I'm not looking
large enough, there'll be- there will be a way to
tile it periodically I just can't find it. And
so he struggled; tried and tried and tried. Then
thought maybe it's something to do with Heesch
numbers? Don't quote me on this but I think it's an
infinite Heesch number, I think you can circle around
infinitely. But he he at one point thought maybe
it's a tile with a very large Heesch number - which I
want to add in because I like the little like pop
animation sound that goes with your Heesch tilings.
He then passed on to Craig Kaplan and said, I've
got this shape and I'm trying as hard as I can
to make it tile periodically and I can't.
And so that was when they started looking
at the computer proofs, kind of running through
could a computer figure out how to make this tile
periodically? Still no; and at that point we have
to start looking at actual mathematical proofs
of this being the solution to the Einstein
problem. It is the one stone which will not
tile periodically.
There is a new tile that
has been invented and we're handing them out
obviously because we're in Newtyle. Are you a
fan of maths at all?
- (Can you fit them together?)
Oh nice!
- (Well done. So the thing that's special is
that it can only be used for that one style)
(of thing? There are lots of things that can do
aperiodic tiling but they also do periodic.)
- Yes
(I'm with you)
- This does aperiodic and that's it.
It has been proved twice - very very cool. And the
first proof involves a situation like this where
we build up meta tiles and super tiles and we
show that they create a structure which forces
aperiodicity. The second one is brand new and
um unseen before. So the idea with meta tiles - and I
think I will go back to this this kind of L chair
aperiodicity. We've looked at them going down the
way and that's kind of a rabbit hole that could go
down and down forever. I could keep splitting each
of these L shapes into more and more L shapes. It
could also go the other direction, can start
with an L shape and ask myself where does this
sit as part of a larger L-shaped tiling? So that's
taking the the L-shaped triomino and then building
out the way. So what we've done for - and I say
we, I was not part of this team at all - but what
humans as- well I mean it's a new
a new stride in human knowledge. So what humans
have done is take the the hat tile and then build
it into meta tiles which look like this. The first
meta tile is just that the hat on its own but
it has a kind of triangle that goes around it.
Then two of the tiles together like this. There is
kind of four points around it that you can join
together to make it look like a parallelogram.
There is another one very similar which makes
sort of a weird pentagon. The F cluster - P was
taken so this is this is the F. And then this one's
my favourite one, this involves three together and
this is the one that includes the backwards. So
yes okay so we've got right hand shirt tucked in
and then the rest are left-hand shirts tucked in.
We have just actually been building a wall
for a few days yeah and this is basically what
I've been doing, so you're giving me a lot of PTSDjust with tiles.
- So we have the meta tile which
- the H meta tile because obviously hexagon -
it is a little bit of an unusual hexagon in
that it's it's irregular so three shorter, three
longer. And for the substitution rules for this
one our hexagon would then be replaced with a
combination of three more hexagons, a few of the
pentagons, and just one of the triangles and it'll
look like this. Drawing skills engage.
So we're saying anytime you see this
hexagon shape, replace that with this
kind of combination of: three more hexagons, a
few pentagons, few parallelograms and then the
triangle which remember represents just
one hat. Then fill it all in with hats. So
finding a substitution tiling that makes
aperiodicity; you know we've had them before,
but finding one that then is all- could
be all filled in with the one same tile,
brand new. Those four meta tiles, they then create
another kind of tiling called super tiles. And
this process of kind of the structure going out
and out means that every single one of the
hats you could locate where it is by looking at
its neighbours. Maybe we should do that with the
L shape. So in this level where we've broken it
down once we've got tiling 1, 2, 3, 4.
And although all the tiles are the same we can
tell where they are. If I were to apply this to
what would be the metatile version of this where
they're broken down again, I can have 1, 2, 3,
4 but these are all in cluster 1. So I can say
okay this is tile 1,2 for example. I could give
it a kind of set of coordinates that means I
can always find exactly where it is. And that
forces aperiodicity because it means each tile-
it only has one place that it fits in. It's it's
unique, it's supposed to be there, I can locate it
and I can say this is the tile, it exists exactly
here and even though I'm looking at an infinite
plane of tilings I know where I am because I know
which cluster, which super tile, which meta tile - I
can locate the address of this exact tile. There
are no tiles which have the same address and so
it causes this aperiodicity. That's- that's the
one that makes more sense, and that's um a type of
proof that has been used for aperiodicity before.
But - there is another.
I think individual tilesit's something like 300.
Nicely done! Well done
I'm particularly good at this - there's one. I actually
do think it is part of being good at maths, I think
it's to do with recognising the the patterns.
So the second proof involves a second tile.
When they discovered the hat - and by they I mean
David Smith - discovered the hat he also discovered
another tile which is made by putting kites
together called the turtle.
- (Oh yeah I'm seeing that)
You see it as a turtle? Yeah so here's the
turtle. When they were first discovered this one
is made out of eight kites joins together; this
one is made of ten kites joined together. So they
were treated as separate entities but they are
in fact one and the same as part of a continuum. If
you look at the angles, you know we've got right
angle down here, a reflex three-quarter angle or
inverted right angle over here. The angles are the
same as we work the way around, the lengths are
different. So if you consider the lengths on the
classic hat - it's a classic now - they're all either
1 or root 3. Again there's a lot of like
cheating going on but I prefer to think of it as-
I don't know, just I wish I had something
philosophical to say. It's not cheating
it's making it work. So um all of the lengths are
either 1 or root 3 apart from one of them
which is 2. But you can think of it as two 1s
joined together. So we have the hat and we have
the turtle and they are part of a continuum of
shapes. If you took all of the edge lengths and
kind of pushed them down so that you made some of
them smaller and some of them bigger depending on
which way you go you get two boundaries. So you
get a chevron and you get what's called a comet
shape. So we'll look at the chevron and the comet.
They tile periodically and there's a middle one
as well right in the middle which looks like a
mix between a hat and a turtle which also tiles
periodically. The underlying grid for the chevron
and the underlying grid for the comet; although
they're both triangular, the the ratios don't
match up, so the lengths don't match. And it means
you can't you can't rectify them, you can't put
them together, they could never- you could never
put the chevron onto the comet grid, you couldn't
put the comet on the chevron grid with the same
area and have them line up with the the lattice
points which is the nice bits on the grid. What
that means is that all of the shapes in between
- like I said aperiodicity is a boundary case-
all of the shapes in between the periodic points
they fall into this no man's land of aperiodicity.
(So does that mean like there are lots and lots of
different shapes not- that are not hats or t-shirts)
(that do this?)
- Yep.
- (Then why do they pick that
particular one to release to the world? Why is that)
(one getting all the fame?)
- I imagine because you can
draw it really nicely on a grid of- a dual grid of
hexagons and triangles together. Something very fun
to do with any pattern is to try and find the dual;
um which is like it's evil twin. If you take
the midpoint of each of the shapes and then
you join them together you'll get another grid.
And so in this case the dual of the triangular
tiling is this hexagon grid, and vice versa.
So the these are where the kites come from;
um the hat is made out of eight of these. If you
see the kite that's created by two dual grids
together, the hat is made out of eight of them
joined together. So that was where it came from.
(So it was sitting in front of our faces)
- Yeah it'slike right there. Yeah yeah I really kicked myself.
(It was waiting to be found, in plain sight)
- Yepbut don't worry we've got it now. You can see
that's the- oh it's this way round one.
- (So Ialways thought the reason that it would have)
(this aperiodic tiling was because things were
constantly rotating at like irrational angles)
(or something, never to repeat. But it's actually
quite an orderly pattern.)
- Yeah you know there's
a weird thing, it is a very orderly pattern. I
think that there's only six orientations that
it would be at, but it doesn't even make use of
all of the orientations that could on this grid
it just sits at six different orientations, the 60
degrees.
- (How did you feel about the announcement?)
First of all incredibly excited; then then I
worried a little bit about the fact that my tattoo
was now out of date - um but overall I was really
happy. I never thought that I would be alive at
a time that something so significant happened
um in terms of maths. I mean we've had way too
many once in a lifetime events in a bad way and
I thought- I just thought, oh my gosh this is this
is genuinely a once in a lifetime event. For
me to be alive during aperiodic monotile time
- overjoyed. And then immediately the first thing
that I wanted to do was turn it into Truchet
tiles. That was an instant thought and then I went
to Twitter and saw someone had already done it. But
luckily they're nice, they do look really good,
I enjoy the Truchet tile version of the hat.
- Who's invented this then?
- So David Smith discovered it and then three other
mathematicians: Joseph Myers, Chaim Goodman-Strauss
and Craig Kaplan proved that there's
definitely not going to be any repeats, yeah.
Do you
know what it would be called to find an aperiodic
monotile which needs no reflection?
- (I don't know)
(but I can tell from your face it's going to be
a pun)
- It's a vampire tile - because it has no reflection?
Check links in all the usual places for some
extra footage and proofs from this interview
with Ayliean. Plus we've got an extra interview
with Craig Kaplan, one of the researchers who
made these amazing discoveries.
- It's awild ride, it's completely unlikely and
should not be taken as a model for how scientific
discovery ever happens, it's completely ridiculous.
- And yes we'll
get to that even newer tile as soon as we
can. Meanwhile if puzzles and patterns are
your thing, maybe you're the sort of person
who could end up having a career with today's
episode sponsor Jane Street. Jane Street's a
research-based trading firm with offices all
across the globe - although perhaps not in Newtyle,
population 800, just yet. Go to their website, check
out the Join Jane Street section for vacancies,
internships, and some free and fun introductory
programs for students. Could be something right
up your alley. Jane Street's a great place to work
and they think the sort of people who like
Numberphile videos might also be the sort of people who
want a career in their offices around the world.
janestreet.com is the place to check them out.
That is the sneaky matching rules that Penrose
tiles use, just hidden as an
underlying grid.
- It was exciting to be
a part of it and I am just so grateful
that that it's causing excitement out
in the world. If it causes anybody to be
you know one little bit more interested in
mathematics, you know then that's fantastic.